I don't see it as giving anything up I
just see it as a change to choose a new
challenge or something it's a new
chapter right
Megan Marco may be adjusting to life as
British royalty but there's one thing
she misses in the USA but her role on
suits while the duchess of sussex was
making a royal appearance in ireland one
fan fiona more recalled telling megan
she was a fan of the USA series and she
missed it then Megan said so do I ready
for this our two beloved characters have
moved on and you know two very close
actor scene partners of ours it was
challenging to know that we're going
into this new season with this like
great fresh reboot with et caught up
with her former co-stars on set ahead of
the new season where they admitted that
there is a void without marko and her
on-screen husband Patrick Jay Adams who
also left the series I wanted to marry
you from the second I met you still her
suits family was thrilled to watch Megan
say I do in real life to Prince Harry
but seeing her walk in on her own that
moment before she met up with Prince
Charles to walk the rest of the way that
was that was amazing
and of course saying goodbye to
Hollywood was always part of the deal
once Megan said yes to Harry's proposal
I think what's been really exciting as
we talk about the transition of this out
of my career but into the role is that
as you said the causes that have been
very important to me I can focus even
more energy on
[Music]